rocking an American Bistro Wow
all right where's the reception right
anyone in
it's like a hallway I'll check in desk
this is behind there
no no somebody's ashes are down there
bloody hell it's not the granddad's
house hello
where's reception oh this is it this is
obscene he should be out in a minute if
you like okay thank you very much
nice to see you i'm on my own it's
confusing
where's the receptionist it's right here
right it's just the reception desk
probably this way okay how old is this
place this hotel was built around 1880s
I think it was decorated 1991 looks that
way the first sign of the last sign it's
been a while for the rooms there is a
closet over here very special hangers
just amazing yep well I think the court
will stay okay just check my view Oh
all those bucks and the blue bottle is
staying for the week there's like a
little faster them down here we give
these to your cleaner I'm sorry
it's like an insect funeral home I look
at this here
I think that's a cockroach to welcome me
on the toy having a number two I'm just
like I can't believe it look at that
never had a cockroach committee welcomed
me on the John let's get out of here and
how would you rate the food one to ten
seven area and if I asked you to rate
your rooms out of ten what would you
give them four or five I'm now [ __ ]
myself about dinner let's hope that the
food is better than the rooms sure the
concept of an American Bistro serving
fresh local food in the country in makes
perfect sense but I can't make any sense
of this menu wow I'm getting a little
bit confused because we've gone Mexican
on the quesadilla we've jumped down to
Thailand and then we got Italian for the
camera yes sir Wow
what would you recommend on the menu we
do a house smoked trout I believe that
it's a golden trout from our Northern
California comes in frozen you're
recommending the IE frozen trout from
Northern California
you know chef it's been only frozen
watch your head is sweating it's a
little high dose of intravenous me I'm
sorry sure no I feel I got a leak in my
sake but I hold head what's these ideas
together that would be Kenny chef okay
so give me a thai-style to play as
bishop yeah an entree dying to see that
Paul Galveston oh yeah it's a chef a
chef are they made in-house no they're
not no thank you
[Music]
Wow
it's just frozen crap reheated in it
happy make slice of chicken look so
bland I wouldn't give that Thai
experience is my [ __ ] dog menu at the
river rock is pretty much outdated it's
Kenny's menu it's been here for years I
don't agree with the menu but it's he's
my boss he pays my salary I'm still
gonna get to that point where you're
just kind of burnt out thank you thank
you Jesus Christ it might it it's like
someone just dropped two [ __ ] t-rex
foot on my plate honestly in fact that
might be a small valve astonished
oh that's a small one yes yeah can the
owner looks like a zombie sleepwalking
towards disaster it's time to get
everyone together and see if I can wait
Ken up how much money are you losing per
month right now about five to seven
thousand a month and that's on the
decline correct if those rooms aren't
that busy why they so disgustingly dirty
they're dirty because I didn't check
them it's almost like we're robbing
customers when I arrived you give your
food seven or eight out of ten yes
but the food was dreadful Steph how long
we be cooking
Oh as a chef 18 years in the business
are you proud of what you sir
personally I don't read it's Kenny's
money on the moon I honestly think that
Kenny needs somebody to open his eyes so
he can see that everybody that works for
him is capable and we're dependable and
we're here to help him increase his
business and make it successful and
nobody's here to hurt him I'm here to
help and it's not as if you're the
captain of the Titanic you're the
[ __ ] iceberg yet you haven't stared
at yourself long enough in the mirror
and actually understood where the issues
are you're looking at them good night
Jesus I've had about all I can take for
one day